voici benoît poelvoorde
alors ils vous ont fait marne est comme
un malade c'est beaucoup travaillé mais
c'est plus difficile de faire la promo
de faire le film non plus parfois plus
long way
ouais incroyable je vous ai vus partout
non peu importe où et quand même
quelques endroits où je ne suis pas allé
oui vous êtes pas allé chez fogiel c'est
vrai c'est vrai oui comme je suis en
tous les cas le film est un succès
considérable je crois que c'est le
deuxième meilleur démarrage de l'année
non oui ça c'est énorme
ah ouais non on est très très content
c'est que j'ai perdu ma voix on a fêté
ça moi j'attendais que ce soit un succès
pour vos invités en fait oui je sais
c'est comme ça il sera cool des
contracteurs là vous n'êtes plus obligé
de bosser à laissez vous aller
complètement la demande ici gentil oui
or mirabaud continuer cet oxygène mais
la jolie natsuki gym est un succès donc
plus de raison de donner du mal en tous
les cas donc je vais quand même vous
vous présentez comme si vous étiez là
comme si vous étiez vous voilà donc vous
avez 37 ans vous êtes belge comédien
scénariste
on vous a vu dans c'est arrivé près de
chez vous dans les randonneurs dans les
convoyeurs attendent dans les portes de
la gloire dans le vélo de ghislain
lambert et aujourd'hui donc dont le
boulet voilà vous avez fait de la scène
aussi avec modèle déposé
j'avais fait de la télé avec les carnets
de monsieur manatane absents sur canal
plus et vous avez eu le prix jean gabin
2002 dames messieurs
et bonjour
c'était lors
bon
merci beaucoup hein c'est comment on
fait les petites mains oui vous m'avez
près attention c'est pour le boulet
mesdames messieurs alors le boulet donc
un film produit par thomas langmann
réalisé par alain berbérian et frédéric
forestier avec vous je ne pensais pas du
tout en même temps et gérard lanvin et
gérard lanvin et gérard darmon et josé
garcia et rossy de palma et jean
benguigui
alors c'est ce qu'on appelle un buddy
movie c'est ce qu'on appelle un
visualiseur film de couple ouais voilà
un studio voilà un film est un film de
duo pierre basé sur un tandem de deux
mecs il y avait eu par exemple emmerdeur
avec lino ventura et jacques brel la
chèvre avec depardieu et pierre richard
la grande vadrouille avec bourvil et de
l'art y voit la traversée pas boudé la
lumière ses nerfs alors le couple
fonctionne très très bien et le coupon
que j'aime bien avec l'ambiance
ah oui vraiment bien mais on s'est bien
entendu on pouvait pas faire le film si
on s'entendait pareil il fallait
s'amuser c'est un film pour s'amuser il
fallait le faire en s'amusant
on s'est bien amusés à le faire on s'est
bien amusés à le tourner on s'est bien
amusés à le présenter à l'heure à le
proposer au public on s'est amusé tout
le temps alors donc j'ai fait le petit
je voulais chasse le pis vous l'avez été
lessivés mieux près alors donc ballan va
c'est un truand c'est même un assassin
il est en tournée il est gardé par un
maton qui est jouée par vous un petit
chefaillon la coume fait si bien
et un jour ils jouent au loto quelques
quelques jours avant ça ça qui y gagne
mais c'est votre femme qui allait
acheter le ticket elle l'a gardé
et malheureusement votre femme qui est
jouée par rossy de palma part comme une
firme hier sur un rallye en afrique
voilà prêt il ya plein d'aventurés
évidemment que je vous laisse découvrir
chers amis téléspectateurs dans un
cinéma près de chez vous voilà et vous
passez votre temps comme ça courir après
garcia qui vous poursuit t il ya un
super méchant qui atteint prêté par josé
garcia et franchement j'aurais aimé un
scoop de son travail vraiment eu très
peur sergio leone un peu oui tout à fait
un moment je faisais là impressionnant
c'est vraiment de la bande dessinée film
est donc c'est vrai qu'ils soient
crédibles c'est du premier degré il
fallait qu'ils soient méchants méchants
mais
il est méchant méchant et ce malgré sa
très petite une amie pour laisser
pousser les cheveux aux jo l'ignorent
mais comme il l'est tout de même de
nationalité espagnole ça n'a pas dû être
bien long